y este vídeo en el que se ve al
periodista detenido román protosevich
despertó dudas a miembros de la
oposición de belarús y también a su
padre
no son sus palabras no es cuanto
nacional hablar
está actuando muy reservado y se nota
que está nervioso es muy probable que
tenga la nariz rota
porque le ha cambiado la forma y tiene
mucho polvo en la cara todo el lado
izquierdo de su cara está con maquillaje
el periodista de 26 años viajaba el
domingo desde atenas hacia vilna junto a
su pareja en un vuelo de la compañía
ryanair la aeronave en la que iba el
disidente fue interceptada por un avión
de combate que lo obligó a desviar su
ruta para aterrizar en minsk frotase
beach fue detenido y según sus aliados
obligado a reconocer en el vídeo su
participación en la organización de las
manifestaciones contra el gobierno de
alexandr lukashenko en 2020 en agosto de
ese año
belarús celebró unas elecciones
presidenciales en las que lukashenko
obtuvo el 80% de los votos y así su
sexto mandato consecutivo en medio de
denuncias de fraude la represión se
acentuó en la que es considerada como la
última dictadura europea miles de
personas se empezaron a manifestar en
las calles de minsk y otras ciudades
activistas periodistas y opositores
fueron detenidos con cerca de 35 mil
personas arrestadas pero esto no es
nuevo
román protosevich es otra víctima el
periodista es él
del canal the telegraph next a que tuvo
un rol importante en la transmisión de
dichas manifestaciones